the central processing unit or cpu is
like the engine in your car
or the brain in your skull and is like a
really fancy calculator
used to run the applications on your
computer when you write software in a
language like javascript or python
you're actually writing a set of
instructions that will be executed as
machine code by a cpu
which itself is a carefully crafted
piece of metal and silicon that contains
billions of tiny transistors
or on off switches that represent ones
and zeros
to perform mathematical calculations a
cpu will combine multiple transistors
together to form logic gates
for example and will take two binary
inputs and validate that both are true
to produce a true output it only takes a
few basic logic gates to solve highly
complex computational problems
modern chips contain billions of
transistors and they can be flipped on
and off billions of times per second
the state of the cpu is synchronized by
an oscillator known as the clock
generator
in general the more times the clock can
pulse per second the faster the cpu can
compute and is normally measured in
gigahertz
gamers will sometimes overclock their
cpus to gain more performance
at the cost of higher temperatures and a
lower life expectancy now in order to
run applications it interacts with the
system memory or ram
in a series of four steps known as the
machine or instruction cycle
step one is the fetch phase think of a
software program as a set of
instructions stored in the ram the cpu
has registers to temporarily store the
address and memory that it wants to
interact with the program counter starts
at 0
and copies that address to the memory
address register then the control unit
sends out a signal to copy the data from
that address
to the instruction register at which
point it needs to figure out how to use
this instruction
in the decode phase the control unit
parses the actual bits in the
instruction
most importantly the opt code contains
the instruction like add or subtract and
the operand is the address in memory to
perform that operation on
the final execute stage takes the
decoded information and passes it as
electrical signals to the relevant parts
of the cpu
the arithmetic logic unit or alu can
perform math on the data and then store
the results in ram to change the state
of the program the cycle is repeated
billions of times per second
and modern chips utilize multiple cpu
cores to run multiple computations in
parallel
that's how a cpu works under the hood
but there's a lot more you should know
about processor architectures if you're
a developer and that's why i've invited
alex from the most underrated tech
channel on youtube
to break down some more advanced
concepts like apple silicon and how to
run performance benchmarking on your own
machine
hi everybody my name is alex and i'm
here to take you beyond 100 seconds in
your quest
to learn about how processor
architectures differ and also how those
differences affect our productivity
as developers i'll show you what the
apple silicon
chip and a refrigerator have in common
and then i'll share some of my own
experiences with using developer tools
and build execution on the first
generation apple silicon chip
called the m1 ship as compared to the
intel chip
first and foremost i just want to say
that my personal productivity as a
developer depends less on processors
inside my computer
and more on how much coffee i had and
whether i'm trying to work after a big
meal
but aside from human factors let's dig
deeper into
why the new apple silicon machines have
been really kicking up a storm and
changing the industry
software development included and
spoiler alert the m1 machines have been
beating the intel machines in pretty
much every build test i've thrown at it
except a couple but it's not all roses
so let's talk about some downsides later
too
so why is it so darn fast the first
point i want to discuss
is the physicality differences of the
new apple silicon way
versus the old intel and amd way this is
what apple silicon and your refrigerator
at home
have in common all right imagine for a
minute that you want to make a turkey
with cheese sandwich
you go over to the refrigerator and in
one place
you have the turkey breast the cheese
the mayonnaise the mustard
all those ingredients are right there in
one place and you don't have to run
around the house to gather them you
don't have to drive to lots of stores to
pick them up
and this saves you lots of time and
energy this kind of efficiency can be
found in the new apple silicon
chips because they aren't just a new
processor
apple silicon is a collection of many
chips that are housed inside
one silicon container and this type of
system is known as a system on chip
or sock and it's essentially an entire
computer
on one chip the main cpu the gpu
the i o controller the ml engine they're
all co-located
so when the task is to make an
electronic sandwich so to speak
or in other words to do some work that
involves all these different components
a system on chip is going to be a lot
more efficient
in terms of energy usage using only a
tiny bit of power
and at the same time it's going to be
faster than say a typical machine that
has all the components
separate intel based machines have a cpu
that's a single
chip and memory is located somewhere
else on the motherboard
the i o is somewhere else the individual
components might be even more powerful
than the ones available at the moment on
the latest apple silicon based machines
but that comes at a cost since these
powerful components are like
supermarkets that carry different
sandwich ingredients
as a result when you want a sandwich on
an intel machine
you'll have to drive all over town
because one store will have the turkey
another store will have the cheese yet
another store will have the mayonnaise
each store might be really good at their
own process and have the best
ingredients
but each store also takes a lot of power
to run losing out on the efficiency
and since all you really want is just to
make a simple sandwich
you're wasting a ton of time and energy
picking up the ingredients from
all the different stores of course some
might say the drawback
with the system on chip design is that
at least for now with the current
selection of apple max you won't be able
to upgrade or change
any of the components you get what's on
the menu and that's it
but that's not news to most people that
are familiar with the apple ecosystem
once you accept that idea you might even
see the benefits of having a more
efficient design
where all the components are on one chip
and they outweigh the cons
and still provide better performance
than the alternative all right
that's enough talk about food so how
does this all affect
real world development workflows so i've
been doing a bunch of developer focused
tests on the latest apple silicon
machines over on my channel
as well as comparing them to other
machines like the intel max and pc
machines too
and in general the new design has been
showing really great promise for my own
workflows as a developer
coffee and sandwiches excluded now there
are lots of technology stacks that
developers use of course
and i'm trying builds in a few of them
but now let me share some of the results
i've seen with node and javascript tests
and after that i'll also discuss the
tech stacks that have the biggest gains
on the new machines
and also the stacks that have the
biggest losses right now at the moment i
started off trying out some existing
javascript tests that are in the browser
and then in node the browser test
consisted of running speedometer
which is a browser benchmark that
measures the responsiveness of web
applications
it uses demo web apps to simulate their
actions such as
adding to-do items you visit the app in
a browser of choice
i tried chrome and safari for this and
you execute the automated test that runs
through a collection of applications
built with some of the more popular
ui frameworks like angular react amber
even vanilla js and jquery and a whole
bunch more
and then this test reports the results
as a single number when it's done
this number represents the runs per
minute and the higher the better when it
was finished i found that it had
significantly more
iterations on the m1 safari had the best
results even going off the scale
and chrome did pretty well too i also
ran some javascript benchmarks in a node
environment
and found a pretty cpu intensive
algorithm called
fancook redux that's implemented in
javascript
and created for benchmarks game a
website that collects
algorithms and tests in different
languages and while my 16-inch
macbook pro with the intel core i9
processor
did beat the macbook air with the m1
chip it really didn't do so by a lot
and when you consider the price
differences between the machines
and the fact that the m1 stayed cool
throughout the test and
that the battery hardly even took a hit
on the m1
you might be thinking whether the extra
few seconds saved while running this
benchmark
on the intel i9 is really worth the
money so running benchmarks is often
very telling
but it doesn't necessarily line up with
real-world scenarios
so that's why i also like to conduct my
own tests whether using my own projects
or other open source projects that are
out there and that commenters
sent to me and here's what i found i ran
a build of the official
nativescript plugins repository which is
a project based on
nx workspaces if you're not familiar
with nx workspaces it allows you to
scale
large javascript and other tech stack
projects
and you can see the nx quickstart right
here on this channel
in my test the build that took about
three minutes on each machine
only differed in build time by tens of
seconds with the m1 macbook air beating
out
the intel macbook pro two out of three
times so
let's talk about what dev stacks benefit
the most from the new apple silicon
chips
at this time for javascript developers
the benefits are already visible
however if you're building mobile apps
for ios for compiling c
plus plus code then this is where you'll
see a 40 to 50 percent improvement
in build times i ran a few xcode builds
and swift builds
and i did some c plus plus algorithms
and built opencv
and webkit in all those tests the m1
came out on top
so what devstacks benefit the least so
far in my own testing any builds that
have to do with running
natively built software and building
using native tooling
has absolutely destroyed intel and speed
and battery performance
native being compiled for the apple
silicon architecture
even when running some software via
apple's rosetta
that's the translation layer that allows
you to run intel and amd based
x64 and x86 programs on the new apple
hardware
even some of those software packages ran
better than on intel
and that's just amazing but there are
workflows that aren't
ready yet in my opinion if you are an
android developer android studio
and official android emulators work on
apple silicon
but they're currently using rosetta for
translations
and while rosetta is generally pretty
good at running x86
targeted code on arm chips it's not
enough for the cpu hungry android
workflows
and i found the results to be not very
usable at the moment
the latest version of dot net which is
version 5 right now
isn't fully supported to run on arm
simple console applications ran just
fine for me
but testing any web workflows like
asp.net core
doesn't work at all yet now it's
expected that by the end of this year
dot net six will come out
it's in alpha right now and we'll have
full support for arm
until then if you need to develop.net
apps i suggest using a pc
with windows oh and if you think you can
use a virtual windows machine
i've tested this as well parallels is
the only vendor that currently supports
the m1
chip to create a virtual windows
environment but the issue is that the
windows guest operating system for arm
is still quite immature and needs a lot
of work also
visual studio 2019 the latest visual
studio offering from microsoft
is unfortunately not compatible with arm
at all and my test is not
stable even using the built-in windows
translation
of x64 software to run on
arm hardware for game developers that
use unity i'm pleased to say that it
works surprisingly
well on apple silicon via rosetta
however it's not as performant as
running natively on x86
but by the time you watch this video
unity might have a version natively
compatible with m1
which i know they're working hard to get
out as soon as possible
overall apple silicon has really put a
boost into many workflows
for developers and other professions and
eventually even gaming
and with the m1 tests we're seeing the
improvements with
just their entry level machines the
upcoming second and third generation
apple silicon machines will be even more
performant and i can't wait to see that
i think it's really gonna help us as
developers move to the next level and i
think it's just gonna lift up the entire
industry
to follow the updates on the new apple
silicon chips as they relate to us
developers as well as seeing me conduct
these tests that i've been discussing
here
consider subscribing to my channel as
well the link is down below
i'm gonna wrap it up there thanks to
fireship for hosting me to share this
amazing new world
that we're about to enter as developers